[Música]
justamente hoy en directo vamos a río de
janeiro con valerie hasta con el
corresponsal de france 24 más de 620.000
personas perdieron la vida en brasil por
el coi 19 y esta semana por primera vez
desde el 5 de enero es decir desde la
llegada a la variante omicron a este
país el promedio semanal de muertos bajó
de los 100 diarios en medio de este
panorama favorable las calles de río se
vuelven a llenar de música y color con
la inauguración del carnaval
valeria vuelve la fiesta tras dos años
de suspensión
después de dos años de pandemia vuelve
el carnaval en el sambódromo de río de
janeiro un carnaval fuera de época en
abril en un ferrero nacional llamado
tiradentes que recuerda a un héroe
nacional que ayudó a liberar un estado
llamado minas gerais vuelve un carnaval
largo que va a durar casi dos semanas
porque vamos a tener durante cuatro días
desfiles los primeros dos días del grupo
de oro en las escuelas de acceso que
disputan una plaza en el grupo especial
viernes y sábado las escuelas más
querida a las 12 esker y viñas de oro
que van a disputar el título de campeona
después la semana que viene el martes
tendremos la votación y finalmente el
sábado el desfile de las campeonas es
decir la escuela que gana y además las
otras 5 que recibieron las mejores notas
es un carnaval
en la historia de río de janeiro no se
recuerda otra vez en que río de janeiro
tuvo dos carnavales porque recordamos
que en febrero las comparsas salieron a
la calle a pesar de la prohibición del
ayuntamiento porque la ola de comida
estaba remitiendo gracias a una
vacunación récord recordamos que el 85%
de la población en brasil está
totalmente vacunado lería pero el
carnaval no es sólo fiesta también
constituye una importante fuente de
ingresos para la ciudad
muy importante para la economía de río
de janeiro no es sólo cierta recordamos
que en años anteriores a la pandemia
llegaban a llegar a río de janeiro más
de un millón de turistas después durante
esos dos años como en el resto del mundo
el turismo quedó muy mermado y ahora el
país está intentando recuperar el flujo
de turistas también lo decíamos antes
gracias a este resultado excepcional de
la vacunación
85% de la población totalmente más y
nada el 40% ya recibió la dosis de
refuerzo y recordamos que el carnaval en
brasil y en río de género concretamente
dura todo el año llega a mover más de 4
mil millones de reales unos 866 millones
de dólares y da trabajo a por lo menos
20 mil personas entre artesanos y todas
las personas que hacen posible esos
carros alegóricos esos disfraces que se
han hecho todos de forma artesanal en la
ciudad del samba además están las
entradas de los casi 70 mil turistas y
cariocas sin brasileños que van
el desfile en el sambódromo y los
hoteles el sector espera una ocupación
del 85 en este carnaval fuera de época
que cae tras dos feriados seguidos la
semana santa el tiradentes y que se
espera inyectar a un poco de dinero a
una economía mermada y castigada por la
inflación